was macht eine gesellschaft aus wer ist
teil davon
und wer nicht welche werte sind uns
wichtig gastfreundschaft gehört sicher
dazu willkommenskultur heißt das bei
unseren deutschen nachbarn
bis ende jahr sollen es mehr als 800.000
flüchtlinge seien gemäss staatlichen
schätzungen deutschland als neue heimat
für die heimatlosen plötzlich ist der
begriff willkommenskultur ganz groß
deutschland erntet respekt für
willkommenskultur
weltklasse mit herz willkommenskultur
das deutsche wunder
jan malte s-bahn gysi der
deutsch-iranische historiker kram von
neun jahren in die schweiz um in zürich
zu forschen
am zentrum für die geschichte des
wissens von uni und eth beschäftigt er
sich mit dem phänomen migration die
willkommenskultur sei ein schöner aber
auch ein schwieriger begriff sagt er
willkommen heißt man gestern und gäste
gehen auch wieder das ist diese
grundlegende problematische assoziation
in diesem willkommen weil diese menschen
die kommen auf gesellschaftlicher ebene
keine gäste sind sondern sind neue
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
der einsatz der deutschen
zivilbevölkerung berührt die welt nur
konkrete migrations konzepte viel
wo sollen die flüchtlinge wohnen wo
dereinst arbeiten die schiere anzahl
menschen stellt die willkommenskultur
auf eine harte probe
inzwischen trauen wir uns wenn nicht
sollten wir uns trauen
das fundamentale dilemma dieser tage
offen auszusprechen
wir wollen helfen aber unser herz ist
weit doch unsere möglichkeiten sie sind
endlich und wir schweizer was ist mit
der willkommenskultur bei uns den heißen
wir eigentlich willkommen und wie 29.000
flüchtlinge prognostiziert das
staatssekretariat für migration für das
ganze jahr 2015 aber auch im hinblick
auf notwendigkeiten des arbeitsmarktes
nützlichkeit wenn man davon ausgeht dass
diese menschen irgendwie bereichert sind
meistens für die wirtschaft gedacht
dann ist diese willkommens bereitschaft
sehr groß ist es nicht der fall dann
wird das ganze schon schon schwieriger
sowie im aargauischen oberwil gehen
dort hat man sich mit 30000 franken
freigekauft
um keine flüchtlinge aufnehmen zu müssen
der gemeindepräsident erklärt er zahle
lieber als asylsuchende im dorf zu haben
warum potenzielle sozialhilfebezüger die
werden uns immer und ewig jahre tasche
liegen nur gerade 30 kilometer von
oberwil lieli entfernt eine andere welt
menschen gehen auf die straße
demonstrieren gegen fremdenhass und für
eine helvetische willkommenskultur
haltung zeigen im herbst großen
flüchtlingsströme etwas tun
während die politik wahlkampf betreibt
im alltag liegen engagement und
überforderung nahe beieinander
es geht darum ob wir migrantinnen und
migranten als künftige mitbürger oder
als belastung für das öffentliche budget
greifen eine anerkennung und das ist
dass wir eigentlich auch auf politischer
ebene längst über gesprochen wir dass
eine willkommens und anerkennungskultur
das eine oder das andere macht keinen
sinn
die willkommenskultur mag als begriff um
fertig sein
sie fragt dich nach kulturellen
unterschieden und belastungsgrenzen aber
sie zwingt uns wichtige fragen zu
stellen
was macht eine gesellschaft aus wer ist
teil davon welche werte sind uns wichtig